bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo bonjour mais qu'elle bouge aussi
alors si vous avez oublié d'allumer la
télé cette semaine que vous avez raté
les principaux événements rester avec
nous on va tout vous dire de l'actualité
de la semaine
c'est le premier grand test pour la
majorité le traité budgétaires européens
le débat a commencé à l'assemblée le
gouvernement compte ces voix il espère
un vote massif mais la gauche reste
divisée y compris au sein du parti
socialiste
comment redonner de la compétitivité à
nos entreprises l'elysée réfléchit
plusieurs pistes sont évoquées
le quotidien le monde croit savoir que
cela passera par la baisse des
cotisations patronales qui serait
financée par une hausse probable de la
cg on en parlera dans votre émission
françois hollande au chevet des élus
locaux des milliers de maires
conseillers généraux régionaux sénateurs
et députés ont participé aux états
généraux de la démocratie territoriale
le gouvernement est bien décidé à écrire
l'acte iii d'une pièce qui dure depuis
30 ans la décentralisation est avec nous
pour évoquer tous ces sujets michel
sapin bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ministre du travail de l'emploi et
du dialogue social et du dialogue en ce
moment il en faut michel sapin mais je
te dire une chose on a essayé de trouver
de vos collègues députés sénateurs
ministres qu'ils aillent peut-être de
retrouver votre point faible peut-être
un petit mot méchant sur vos mains on a
eu beaucoup de mal je vous propose
d'écouter un peu ces témoignages se
démonte jamais
il est constant dans ses choix
bref je les aime bien il a aussi pas mal
d'humour en cela d'ailleurs il a une
certaine ressemblance avec le président
de la république il n'avait pas le
couteau entre les dents il n'est pas
agressif il est plein d'humour il est
capable d'entendre je ne connais pas de
défauts je vous en trouvez un laissez
moi réfléchir je suis si vous emploi le
tout le monde me trouve sympathique
il n'est peut-être pas aussi facile
qu'on le dit finalement je le connais
bien et il fait pas de cadeaux en
politique j'ai à part lundi intelligent
je trouve pas c'est qu'être être trop
intelligent c'est parfois ça joue
parfois contre soi perte de
compétitivité et baisse de la croissance
ça va faire beaucoup plus de chômage de
faim que monsieur sapin soit le seul qui
ait bientôt du travail dans notre pays
je trouve qu'il n'a pas été bien traité
dans ce gouvernement
beh je pense qu'il aurait pu au moins au
minimum syndical
être à bercy voilà soit matignon soit
bercy n'est pas au moins ça vous a fait
selon michel sapin
homme de consensus ou consensuelle non
mais je pense qu enfin chacun a sa
personnalité
enfin pas toujours très très difficile
de parler de soi même mais j'essaye de
marier des convictions je crois forte et
qui n'ont pas varié tout au long de la
vie politique depuis que je me suis
engagé au parti socialiste j'avais 22
ans premier combat électoral était à 25
ans à argenton-sur-creuse la ville dont
je suis aujourd'hui l'élu donc j'essaie
d'avoir la conviction et de la
continuité et en même temps je pense que
c'est pas par le conflit
il ya toujours des conflits mais qui
sait pas par le conflit que on peut
arriver à résoudre les grands problèmes
de la france d'hier politique il faut
être un petit peu tueur ou l'efs vous
peut-être peut-être que pour vraiment
réussir pour obtenir les plus hauts
postes du il faut il faut être tueur bon
c'est pas moi c'est pas ma nature voilà
je peux pas faire du mal aux autres je
pense comme en face du nouveau non plus
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est pour ça
peut-être justement comme l'a dit
maurice leroy
vous n'avez pas eu bercy votre nom a été
rien me sentais matignon je connais je
connais bien maurice leur charge
je vois bien aussi comment dirais-je les
astuces qui peut y avoir derrière cela
dont je suis très très fier du poste que
j'occupe françois hollande a souhaité
que ce soit moi qui soit ce poste là
c'est donc pas par défaut du tout je
crois qu'on en voit aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs l'importance que ce soit
compte tenu de la bataille contre le
chômage
où que ce soit pour essayer de
promouvoir enfin en france un vrai
dialogue social que vous n'êtes pas un
peu le brice hortefeux de françois
hollande l'ami fidèle des caméras on est
fait mais l'ami fidèle depuis 30 35 ans
françois hollande mais pas forcément les
postes les plus en vue côté vous pensez
en tout cas vous aimez moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de responsabilités déjà
donc j'ai déjà été mises l'économie et
des finances sommes servent dans le
poste où je suis aujourd'hui parce qu'il
n'ya pas le travail contre l'économie
c'est un ensemble qu'il faut faire
fonctionner j'ai vidéo d'autres
responsabilités dans la réforme de
l'état ou dans la gestion la fonction
publique ça me sert aussi aujourd'hui
dans les réformes qui sont qui sont
nécessaires et dans la mise en en marche
d'une administration qui a été très mal
traités au cours de ces dernières années
voilà donc je suis extrêmement fier du
poste que j'aime énormément de travail à
faire il ya beaucoup de réussite moi ce
que je cherche toujours dans l'action
c'est pas simplement le le commentaire
quotidien il faut le faire mais c'est
aussi qu'est-ce qu'on peut laisser comme
traces profondes comme traces profondes
si on n'arrive vraiment à mettre en
place un dialogue social à la française
ce sera une trace qui restera allez on
commence avec lundi et la mort annoncée
de la sidérurgie en lorraine
60 jours le compte à rebours est lancé
c'est le délai accordé bas arcelormittal
au gouvernement pour trouver un
repreneur
le groupe qui a confirmé la fermeture
définitive des hauts fourneaux de
florange 629 salariés sont sur la
sellette
yoann relais et châteaux villanove une
quinzaine d'ouvriers de florange pour un
baroud d'honneur très symbolique dans
une ambiance électrique
la délégation est venue chahuter les
membres de la direction d'arcelormittal
à leur passage devant le siège social à
l'intérieur
un comité central d'entreprise s'apprête
à débuter pour statuer sur l'avenir du
site de florange une décision que
beaucoup d'ouvriers présents redoutent
les semble déjà connaître encore nous
coûter si aujourd'hui on a de l'espoir
c'est clair et net
l'espoir viendra du gouvernement presque
sans suspense
mais aussitôt suivi d'un mouvement de
colère des responsables syndicaux
présents à la réunion
tu vois c'est le début de quelque chose
je vous dis tout ce qui était jusqu'à
maintenant c'était rigolade à partir de
maintenant on vraiment lui il accepte un
peu après 11 heures c'est officiel
arcelormittal ferme définitivement le
site de florange sans pour l'instant
évoquer de plan de reprise
on nous a simplement annoncé la fin de
la filière liquide
on peut pas accepter ça on ne peut pas
l'accepter
il faut une autre politique industrielle
monsieur ban de bourg doit choisir sans
qu'on soit avec les salariés soit les
prédateurs de nouveau appelé à la
rescousse le gouvernement pour le parti
socialiste
une priorité une seule trouver un
repreneur pour la totalité du site
une solution à laquelle la direction
d'arcelormittal reste pour l'instant
opposé l'état fera tout pour aller
chercher ce repreneur mais qu'
arcelormittal cède non seulement les
hauts fourneaux mais le reste pour qu'il
puisse y avoir une cohérence d'une
activité qui se maintiennent en lorraine
un bras de fer de deux mois avec le
groupe arcelormittal en perspective et
une proposition de loi pour faciliter
les rachats de sites industriels dans
l'intervalle l'avenir de la sidérurgie
française
continuera donc de s'écrire au
conditionnel malgré les promesses on se
souvient de françois hollande qui était
venu à florange lors de la campagne
présidentielle vous n'avez pas réussi à
éviter la fermeture de florent était aux
fourneaux
est-ce que c'est pas un peu un constat
d'échec moi je me souviens de promesses
du précédent président de la république
qui était allé dans un autre site
d'ailleurs en disant jamais ça ne
fermera saint ferme et derrière et je me
souviens de ce qu'a dit françois
hollande quand il était allé là bas il
n'a pas dit jamais ça fermera qu'a dit
je ferai tout pour vous accompagner
je ferai tout vous vous aider l'état ne
décide pas de tout dans une entreprise
comme celle ci mais il doit accompagner
il doit être présent c'est ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui
et effectivement pour les salariés eux
mêmes qui sont dans une bataille vital
c'est vraiment leur vie celle non
seulement leur travail mais c'est leur
vie c'est leur environnement c'est
quelque chose d'absolument décisif
je veux simplement souligné que ça a
bougé ce que lars eller mittal a caché
pendant très longtemps je veux fermer
fermé pour fermer s'est transformé en je
vais fermer mais je n'ai j'accepte que
s'engagent des négociations pour que les
hauts fourneaux et les éléments
essentiels qui permet de faire
fonctionner ses hauts fourneaux soit
rachetée donc arnaud montebourg et le
gouvernement vous pensez que ça peut
bouger encore un petit peu dans les
semaines qui viennent mais je sais que
nous ne croyez pas aux miracles mais
éventuellement est-ce qu'on peut avancer
quelques remixes aucun domaine
mais ce cas faire arnaud montebourg y
compris sa présence là bas qui était
extrêmement courageuse chacun peut le
juger c'est pas simple d'être en face
physiquement de ceux qui sont là dans la
dans la détresse et qui exige qu'il se
passe quelque chose d'autre il ya ce
qu'il a réussi à faire lui le
gouvernement le président de la
république sait que arcelormittal
reculent et accepte que il y est une
possibilité de maintien d'activités de
ses hauts fourneaux avec le rachat par
une autre entreprise
il faut maintenant trouver cet autre
entreprise diana tandis qu elle m ce
rachat est ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus aujourd'hui sur sk des
pistes vous avez déjà des noms qui
circulent sur un possible repreneur je
vais pas vous donner de noms que je n'ai
pas c'est aujourd'hui bien sûr au
ministre au pluriel concernés très
directement de le faire ils le font je
sais qu'il ya tout un travail en ce
moment de contact avec un certain nombre
d'acier de
producteur d'acier qui pourraient être
intéressées elles cinq ans l'a beaucoup
entendu en tout cas dans les mondes
d'opposition ou même ailleurs
il ya qu à nationaliser est ce que
l'état peut aujourd'hui encore
nationaliser ce genre entreprises non
chanteur de 50 ans surtout dans une
partie à l'extrême gauche mais chacun
voit bien que c'est pas un état c'est
pas un gouvernement de fabriquer de
l'acier
ça a pu exister à d'autres moments dans
le passé ça n'a jamais montré son
efficacité
donc c'est aux entreprises et aux
entrepreneurs de gérer la production
mais c'est à l'état d'accompagner et
surtout de créer des conditions qui
permettent que cela des pauvres on va
parler de ce moment de la compétitivité
des entreprises devraient venir après
mais ça c'est à l'état de créer ces
conditions
et puis c'est aussi à nous là c'est plus
mon travail à moi d'accompagner ces
mutations lorsqu'il ya des mutations qui
sont inévitables
il faudrait le prendre beaucoup plus tôt
là on le prend dans la catastrophe
on le prend dans le drame on le prend
dans l'urgence dans la fermeture on
prend dans la violence une violence
souci social qui s'exerce il faudrait
anticiper ces évolutions et là c'est un
des sujets qui est aujourd'hui dans la
grande négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux que j'ai souhaité que le
président a fui qu'à souhaiter
on va changer de sujet michel sapin ça
se passe également lundi on va parler de
ce drame qui a touché la ville
d'echirolles près de grenoble ou de
jeunes adultes ont été passés à tabac la
ville est toujours sous le choc alors
accompagné du ministre de l'intérieur
françois hollande s'est rendu sur place
il a tenté de rassurer les habitants
vous allez le voir sur cette scène entre
les riverains et le président elle
rappelle d'autres images plus ancien
président j'ai mon diplôme
eh bien ils ont le droit à la sécurité
c'est ce que je suis venu leur apporter
sécurité justice et réussite
françois hollande interpellé par une
riveraine après les meurtres
d'echirolles dans la banlieue
grenobloise
le chef de l'état lui répond du tac au
tac et s'érigent en justiciers
le président de la république a changé
mais la scène paraît familière car dans
l'attitude et dans le ton françois
hollande se rapproche de son
prédécesseur nicolas sarkozy si vous
n'avez les transformations mais pour
travailler parfois nialé comme si on
n'avait pas de formation qualifiante
n'avait aucune chance au vide en sortir
tout comme nicolas sarkozy en avait pris
l'habitude
suite aux faits divers d'echirolles où
de jeunes sans histoire se sont fait
sauvagement assassinée françois hollande
et son ministre de l'intérieur se sont
rendus sur place et ont passé du temps
avec les familles des victimes
dans la foulée de la visite une dizaine
d'interpellations et des annonces de
manuel valls y aura et vous le savez
nous y travaillons avec monsieur le
préfet avec le directeur départemental
de la sécurité publique avec le
procureur des zones de sécurité
prioritaire elles concerneront
évidemment ces quartiers et il y aura
cela va de soi des moyens
supplémentaires parce qu'il manque des
moyens notamment en matière de voie
publique
le message est clair l'exécutif agit
pour la sécurité des français des
avocats des gardés à vue dénoncent déjà
une surenchère sarkozy à michel ça pour
voir parler du fond évidemment dans
quelques secondes mais vous avez vu ces
images est ce qu'elle ne vous rappelle
pas celle par exemple la dalle
d'argenteuil à l'épaule avec nicolas
sarkozy n'en ressemble en fait du
nicolas sarkozy franchement je ne suis
pas du tout d'accord avec le commentaire
qui est fait qui consisterait à faire un
parallèle absolue entre la manière
d'être de nicolas sarkozy dans un drame
comme celui ci est la manière d'être de
françois hollande je trouve au contraire
ce qui s'est passé montre la différence
profondément la vivent qu'est ce qui est
différent c'est pas que le président en
afrique se déplacent c'est normal a fait
divers une visite non pas un fait divers
une visite mais là c'est quand même pas
n'importe quel type de faits divers
toute mort est terrible bien entendu on
a vu dans quelles conditions de
sauvagerie dans quelles conditions
fuiter ces actes ont été commis donc
devant une émotion le président de la
république qui a une relation
personnelle avec les français français
ils ont ils ont élus qu'ils aient voté
pour qu'ils aient voté contre
qu'ils se déplacent c'est pas du tout ça
qui est en cause c'est normal de se
déplacer mais c'est la manière de faire
et même si là vous n'avez pas passé les
mêmes mots les mêmes mots que ce qu'on a
pu entendre sur la dalle d'argenteuil
il fallait passer au kärcher qu'est ce
que dit par contre françois hollande il
faut de la justice il faut de la
sécurité de la marche pas je ressemble
dans les différentes
les images sont très différentes le
discours est très différent c'est
deuxième grande différence à chaque fois
que nicolas sarkozy sortait de quelque
part il annoncé une loi un nouveau texte
d'ailleurs les trois quarts de ces
textes ne soient pas été voter soit pas
été appliqué là non il ya une annonce de
quoi des moyens des moyens ce dont on a
besoin c'est des moyens c'est des cd des
policiers c'est des juges qui puisse
juger plus rapidement
donc c'est cela la grande différence
plutôt que d'être dans la proclamation
et dans l'insulté
vous avez un président de la république
qui est proche qui est dans la
commisération
mais qui est aussi dans le concret on
apporte les moyens nécessaires alors on
l'a vu un sur ces images
à côté de françois hollande il y avait
bien sûr manuel valls de jean-manuel
d'ailleurs regardez c'est beaucoup de
manuel valls cette semaine et notamment
cette une du nouvel obs
manuel valls est ce que c'est le
vice-président de toutes les unes sont
possibles et vous savez comment
fonctionne la presse aujourd'hui vous
avez un coup de batte chine comme on dit
et puis alors j'ai cherché le mot en
sens inverse
non j'ai pas trouvé bon fait de gros
mais on met en avant une valse mérite
d'être mis en avant c'est donc on va
prendre des mots des mots français
mais après ça faisait ça change à ces
choses là mais manuel valls fait un
travail exceptionnel il le fait avec la
force la force de la conviction la force
de la personnalité parce que la sécurité
c'est de gauche
est ce que c'est de gauche la sécurité
c'est pas un mot de droite c'est pas un
comportement de droite la sécurité pour
les plus jeunes
vite je sers masque c'est la fifa voilà
voyez s'il a eu peut-être dangereux la
gauche n'est pas ce danger lit qu'elle
ne l'a jamais été même s'il peut y avoir
des propos parce que c'est vrai que la
sécurité c'est aussi en amont c'est
toute la prévention mais il ya un moment
donné où la sécurité c'est quand il ya
un fait répréhensible
on le condamne on le poursuit et on
condamne la personne qualifie ce fait ce
que cette montée en puissance de manuel
valls agace manuel valls chouchou dans
les sondages jean marc ayrault lui
descend au moins neuf points ce que ça
agace moi ça m'agace pas du tout non
reposer la question à d'autres mais je
ne pense pas je ne vois pas des visages
agacé je pense qu'il ya des visages qui
sont contents d'avoir soi comme collègue
c'est mon cas soit comme le ministre de
son gouvernement
c'est le cas du président de l'epic ou
du premier ministre des ministres qui
font bien leur boulot on va passer au
mardi le débat sur le traité européen
s'invite à l'assemblée nationale voilà
quarante minutes pour convaincre les
élus rétif le premier ministre à un défi
réunir une majorité de gauche pour
ratifier le traité européen jean marc
ayrault a voulu rassurer les députés
écouter la responsabilité devant
laquelle chacun d'entre nous et placé
jeudi bien chacun d'entre nous est
placée est crucial c'est de maintenir la
france dans une zone euro solidaire car
la conséquence d'un rejet
ce serait et vous le savez bien une
crise politique
l effondrement de l'union monétaire le
vote auquel je vous invite et celui de
la confiance dans la politique
européenne engagée depuis quatre mois
par françois hollande elle a déjà porté
ses fruits et l emportera d'autres alors
a traité européen qui divise à gauche
jean marc ayrault a sorti les grands
moyens pour tenter de convaincre les
derniers récalcitrants pération
séduction lors de la réunion du groupe
ps à l'assemblée et machines la pression
auprès des derniers récalcitrants
une dizaine de socialistes qui refusent
toujours de voter le traité une partie
des députés écologistes et le front de
gauche restent eux sur leur position et
votre rencontre jean baptiste daoulas
c'est avant tout un avertissement
politique que jean marc ayrault est venu
adresser au député socialiste françois
hollande a beaucoup changé les choses
c'est bien donnons-lui encore plus par
la ratification de ce traité les moyens
de son action
pas question d'affaiblir la majorité un
message entendu par la majorité des
socialistes
le premier ministre est accueilli par
une standing ovation aux réunions de
groupe mais le noyau dur des opposants
au traité ne changera pas d'avis on va
pas faire bouger les lignes dans les
dernières discussions du moment mais on
va continuer à envisager ensemble
comment est-ce qu'on prépare les
prochaines échéances parce que ça le
plus important
le prochain traité ce traité pour moi là
il déjà caduque une certaine mal au
final seulement 13 députés socialistes
ont voté contre le traité
le gouvernement a sorti ses calculettes
il ne devrait pas avoir besoin des voix
de l'ump
dans les autres groupes de gauche les
radicaux voteront massivement pour à une
ou deux exceptions près al'inverse les
écologistes restent farouchement opposés
au traité
le texte n'a pas bougé nous trouvions
mauvais il ya quelques mois nous
trouvons toujours mauvais quant aux
communistes
il compte déjà déplacé le combat au
sénat si 30 sénateurs ou sénatrice la
cygnet il y en avant dans notre groupe
donc nous pensons que c'est possible que
d'autres se joignent à nous eh bien nous
pourrons déposée en début de débat une
motion référendaire et mettre cette
question du retour devant le peuple au
centre du débat parlementaire
le but d'une motion référendaire est de
proposer un référendum au président de
la république une procédure
essentiellement symbolique qui a très
peu de chances d'aboutir
est ce que vous n'avez pas un peu des
alliés un peu trop encombrant le sujet
européen a toujours divisé diviser la
gauche
on l'a vu à d'autres pays divisé la
droite parce que vous faites le sujet
sur la gauche je comprends bien c'est
nous qui sommes au pouvoir et c'est nous
qui allons apporter la majorité
nécessaire mais je vois aussi au sein de
la droite à peu près en nombre ego un
certain nombre de gens qui voient la
honte un discours qui t'inspire
anti-européen nous nous appartenons à
cette gauche qui croient en l'europe
mais pas n'importe quelle europe et pas
n'importe comment
et c'est pour ça qu'il fallait
absolument rééquilibrer le traité dit
budgétaire de ces volets de
croissance et de solidarité c'est ce
qu'a apporté la bataille de françois
hollande c'est ce que le sommet de juin
dernier qui est très important qui qui
marquera vraiment une rupture entre
l'avant et l'après à apporter il ya la
stabilité budgétaire qui est nécessaire
en france comme ailleurs et à la
solidarité qui est nécessaire c'est
l'allemagne ac est en cause
et puis il ya la croissance avec un
budget de dépenses d'investissement au
niveau européen qui va être mise en
oeuvre
alors vous l'avez dire on a parlé des
récalcitrants vous est peut-être en
train d'essayer de récupérer quelques ça
mais vous avez y aura une majorité de
gauche voilà la question sera une vraie
majorité du parti socialiste ou pas faut
du parti socialiste et pas que la parti
socialiste à gauche donc vous avez parlé
du groupe des radicaux je pense que au
sein des verts les choses sont pas aussi
clairs que cela chez les verts c'est
jamais très clair donc il ya toujours un
pour 1 contre et qui s'abstient ce sera
le cas là aussi parce que chacun le
droit aussi à ses propres convictions
bien donc je pense je pense moi je ne
suis pas là pour compter à l'unité près
mais je pense qu'il aura une majorité de
gauche et ça ne me gêne pas
objectivement qui est aussi des voix de
droite qui se portent sur un traité
comme celui ci et sur le paquet lui-même
parce que la construction de l'europe
j'aime l'europe de gauche mais je sais
bien qu'elle n'est pas construit ce que
par des gens de gauche a sur le fond
cette fois vous avez vu que l'allemagne
avance les autres pays aussi avancé le
signe des traités ça s'est fait de leur
côté ils vont bien plus loin il part
déjà d'europe fédérale
est-ce qu'on est à la traîne est ce
qu'on est encore écouter ce que notre
voix porte encore michèle sabban oui
c'est surtout l'allemagne qui est qu'ils
proposent à ce qui est d'ailleurs très
traditionnelle chez elle et l'allemagne
est prête à faire un effort mais à
partir du moment où c'est un effort qui
serait portée à un niveau fédéral a
l'habitude de cela elle s'est construite
autour de ceux de ce mécanisme
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut prendre
les choses étape après étape
quel est le problème de l'europe
aujourd'hui l'europe inquiète l'europe
est en panne de croissance l'europe
inquiète par les divisions par les
risques sur sa monnaie donc la priorité
des priorités
y compris pour retrouver de la
croissance y compris pour trouver de
l'emploi c'est de stabiliser de nouveau
l'europe c'est que l'europe aujourd'hui
c'est le problème du monde
c'est le problème économique du monde si
le monde va mal aujourd'hui du point de
vue économique soit aux états unis ou en
chine
c'est parce que l'europe se porte mal
donc nous devons répondre d'abord et
avant tout chose régler cette question
là
pour retrouver la stabilité de la
visibilité de la croissance l'europe et
sans croissance n'est pas que la france
l'europe et sans croissance ça ne peut
pas continuer comme ça et c'est ça qu'il
faut d'abord régler
après il y aura un travail pour voir sur
quel dans quel domaine
après quels outils par exemple l'union
bancaire qui est un outil très important
pour pouvoir construire une europe
autrement aller mercredi où la potion
amère d sanofi un haka un cri de guerre
de colère devant l'assemblée nationale
un millier de salariés de sanofi ont
défilé mercredi à paris contre le plan
social du groupe qui menace plus de 900
emplois d'ici 2015
une grande journée de mobilisation qui
s'est terminée devant le palais bourbon
où arnaud montebourg a accueilli les
salariés ras aby cas sous la pluie un
millier de salariés du groupe sanofi
venus de toute la france ils expriment
leur désaccord concernant le projet de
réorganisation de l'entreprise
arnaud montebourg est rapidement prise à
partie par les employés cela monsieur
vie barreur a reculé déjà deux fois
nous attendons qu'ils reculent encore
une troisième fois et s'il doit reculer
une quatrième
il faudra qu'ils reculent une quatrième
fois selon le ministre sanofi prévoyez
2500 suppressions de postes suite aux
pressions gouvernementales le groupe
aurait revu ce chiffre à 900
licenciements mais pour les employés du
géant pharmaceutique c'est toujours trop
pour notre part on estime que l'état
devrait faire plus en prono c'est une
activité stratégique
cette activité de santé la santé c'est
la sphère de tous y compris de
gouvernement pour nous il est
inadmissible
qu'une société comme sanofi avec les
profits réalisés une autre une
entreprise qui vit de la santé donc de
la sécurité sociale et qui décide de
plan de restructuration simplement pour
augmenter les dividendes versés aux
actionnaires
c'est absolument intolérable
inacceptable
les syndicats ont été reçus à
l'assemblée nationale par des députés du
parti socialiste un nouveau rendez vous
est d'ores et déjà prévue le 12 octobre
cette prochaine réunion devrait
rassembler cette fois-ci
l'intersyndicale le gouvernement ainsi
que la direction du groupe et les élus
alors le groupe sanofi a dégagé 1 5 7
milliards d'euros de bénéfices en 2011
l'année dernière est-ce qu'il faut
légiférer pour interdire les
licenciements boursiers
mais aujourd'hui à licenciements
boursiers est il légal si sanofi devait
prendre comme prétexte pour licencier
des salariés
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il faut empêcher
un des licenciements qui font que les
gens se retrouvent à pôle emploi
ils seraient condamnés par la justice
parce que c'est pas un argument on n'a
pas le droit de rompre un contrat de
travail qui engage entre une entreprise
et un salarié au motif simplement qu'il
faudrait encore plus augmenter les
profits des actionnaires
les seuls arguments que l'on a le droit
d'avancer c'est il faut anticiper une
évolution il faut faire attention parce
que tel médicament ou tel autre s'il
marche bien aujourd'hui il peut marcher
moins bien dans trois mois dans un an
dans trois ans donc les évolutions les
anticipations sont légitimes mais par
contre du licenciement parce qu'il
faudrait augmenter les profits boursiers
c'est déjà aujourd'hui illégitime mais
je voudrais que ça aille plus vite
il faut il faut il faut modifier la loi
sur les licenciements
parce que le problème ce n'est pas tant
le motif le licenciement boursier c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce motif la cette
annulation
elle interviendrait après le
licenciement et ça serait jugée par le
juge
deux ans trois ans quatre ans après mais
c'est pas ça que veulent les salariés
les salariés veulent conserver leur
emploi
et c'est là dessus qu'il ya une réforme
du licenciement qui est absolument
nécessaire pour que les salariés
puissent anticiper puisse intervenir
plus tôt que la décision surprise plutôt
que le motif du licenciement soit en
quelque sorte jugez plutôt
et c'est cela aussi ceux dont les
partenaires sociaux sont aujourd'hui
saisi
vous allez la fréquence est très vite
qu'il y aura une loi sur les
licenciements
il faut modifier leur concéder
licenciement simplement la méthode que
nous utilisons cette fois ci c'est une
méthode qui consiste à demander à ceux
qui connaissent cela qu'ils vivent dans
l'entreprise du côté employeurs comme du
côté salariés à négocier sur le grès de
la modification des procédures
mais de toute façon il y aura une loi
s'il n'y a pas d'action fécond déjà au
sénat a été voté par une proposition de
l'organisme et les lois sont une chose
la réalité sociale c'est important la
réalité sociale non mais si je vais vous
répondre
la réalité sociale c'est très important
donc les partenaires sociaux aujourd'hui
se sont saisis de cela commençait hier
ils ont déjà commencé à en parler
d'ailleurs on a vu les différences
d'appréciation le gouvernement le
président de la république souhaite ont
souhaité que les négociations soient
terminées à la fin de l'année donc au
début de l'année prochaine
d'une manière ou d'une autre je préfère
que ce soit à la suite d'un accord il y
aura une loi qui modifiera la procédure
de licenciement offrant alors michel
simplement pas sur un autre sujet celui
de la compétitivité on sait évidemment
que là aussi il y a beaucoup de débats
savoir comment financer cette
compétitivité par le coût du travail
baisse de la csg ou pas les explications
de d'elisa bartholomé c'est une variable
que l'elysée semblait avoir oublié et
qui revient avec force la compétitivité
des entreprises
l'exécutif réfléchit à baisser le coût
du travail
alors que la barre des 3 millions de
chômeurs vient d'être franchi une
proposition émergent diminuer une partie
des cotisations patronales des
entreprises et compenser le manque à
gagner pour la sécurité sociale par une
augmentation de la csg
un sujet qui divise même au sein du
gouvernement
certains s'opposent à une augmentation
de la csg au nom du pouvoir d'achat mais
officiellement rien n'est tranché
nous avons suffisamment dénoncé la tva
sociale telle que la pratique et le
précédent gouvernement pour ne pas avoir
envie d'y recourir
quant à la csg je crois que ça n'est pas
non plus la réponse idoine l'elysée
pensent augmenter la csg de 40 milliards
d'euros étalé sur cinq ans pour ne pas
trop pénaliser les ménages cela
représenterait une hausse de 8 à 10
milliards par an et un choc de
compétitivité pour les entreprises
à droite on condamne cette proposition
mais ça n'est pas une bonne réponse
ce n'est pas une bonne réponse parce que
autant la tva emploi qui consistait à
baisser les charges pour améliorer la
compétitivité pour taxer davantage les
importations étaient bonnes autant
augmenter la csg
ça pénalise la consommation et ça n'a
pas d'impact sur les importations
jean marc ayrault l'a assuré pas
d'augmentation de la csg en 2013 pour
le débat est ouvert le haut conseil sur
le financement de la protection sociale
et la remise du rapport de louis gallois
sur la compétitivité lui permettront de
trancher
michel sapin ce débat est important il
va falloir essayer d'être pédagogique et
essayer de bien comprendre alors est ce
que ce débat va porter sur combien ça
coûte
ou comment reste confidentiel à
compétitivité on a besoin de vos
lumières
bah justement si on commence comme ça on
n'est pas pédagogique il n'en sera pas
pertinent et si en plus on si en plus on
le fait à partir de rumeurs
ceci quelqu'un pour l elysée pourrais je
sais pas qui est l'elysée moi je sais
une maison où l'elysée pour moi ce n'est
pas une personne
bon voilà donc c'est mal parti c'est pas
comme ça qu'il faut agir et qu'il faut
réfléchir
quel est le problème problème de base
c'est que nous avons 70 milliards de
déficit de notre commerce extérieur
ça peut pas continuer il faut donc qu'on
vendre plus à l'extérieur et que l'on
soit plus con capacité de tenir le coup
par rapport à des produits importés ça
c'est décisif parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya des milliards de commerce
extérieur en moins enfin en négatif
c'est des centaines d'emplois en moins
aussi sur le territoire voilà la
question est ce que c'est le problème de
toute l'économie française non vous avez
un quart au maximum un quart de
l'économie française qui est dans la
compétition internationale
quand je vous allez chez le boulanger il
n'est pas dans la compétition
internationale
quand vous allez dans un casino où dans
ce sont les entreprises qui sont de la
compétition à ces entreprises là celles
qui sont dans la compétition
internationale qu'il faut apporter une
réponse pour leur permettre de mieux
faire face à cette grande concurrence
c'est quand on dit cela déjà comme ça
c'est pas toutes les entreprises c'est
pas pour tout le monde et c'est pas des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliards
chez les saints évite d'avoir ensuite
des solutions qui consisterait à
augmenter massivement la csg ou
massivement la tva comme c'était prévu
autrefois qui aurait des conséquences
épouvantables sur le pouvoir d'achat
que vaut la consommation et sur le
fonctionnement des économies donc il
faut pas d'augmentation massive la cj ça
n'a aucun sens ça fait combien
mais non mais il faut pas d'augmentation
de la csg comme réponse à 40 milliards
ça n'a pas de sens et spa car
aujourd'hui on sait combien il faut au
travail donc je vais pas vous donner le
nombre de milliards on regarde quel est
le secteur de l'économie française qu'il
faut aider qui laquelle il faut apporter
une solution
comment le faire il ya plein de
possibilités de faire ça peut être en
diminuant les cotisations je préfère le
terme de cotisation à celui de charges
et cotisations se sert à quelque chose
en partie à la sécurité sociale
donc on peuvent diminuer les cotisations
pour certaines entreprises ou certaines
parties des salaires de ces entreprises
qui sont prêts vraiment dans la
compétition internationale
il ya aussi quelques impôts qui pèsent
sur la production il ya des impôts
locaux s'appelle la cotisation foncière
des entreprises
une proposition que françois hollande a
fait dans le dans la campagne qui pèse
principalement sur les usines on va dire
donc sur l'industrie donc il ya aussi
quelques impôts de cette nature qui
peuvent être baissés donc vous voyez que
il n'ya pas deux y a pas de réponse
globale via pas de révéler quant à steve
dès qu'on raisonne globalement et
massivement ça ne marche pas et je
termine sur un point je n'aime pas le
terme de choc de compétitivité
parce que je vous dire la france en ce
moment elle en prend des coups des chocs
il ya le choc de la compétition
internationale il ya le choc aujourd'hui
delà de la stabilité de l'europe
il ya aussi le choc des déficits
budgétaires qu'il faut combler donc
rajoutons pas les chocs aux chocs
trouvant des solutions précises
concrètes qui permettent d'être efficace
plutôt que de vouloir faire du choc pour
le pays nordique à la question juste une
dernière question parce que c'est
vraiment très important
est ce que finalement au fond est-ce que
c'est pas la durée du temps de travail
qui pose problème
non non monsieur je vois pas pourquoi la
durée posera un problème c'est pas la
durée il s'est éventuellement le coût de
ce travail dans certains secteurs
j'aime pas quand on dit un problème de
coût du travail en france est pas vrai
y'a pas de problème de coût du travail
en france il ya un problème dans
certains secteurs qui sont dans la
compétition internationale très clair
allez on enchaîne avec jeudi et des
entrepreneurs qui ne veulent pas se
faire plumer
les pigeons ont réussi à faire plier le
gouvernement pierre moscovici et fleur
pellerin vont devoir revoir leur copie
face à la grogne des créateurs
d'entreprise contre l'augmentation des
plus values sur les cessions de sociétés
de gouvernements a promis des
aménagements fiscaux chloé maïs presque
une semaine que les entrepreneurs
faisait fronde contre le gouvernement en
cause la taxation sur les plus values
réalisées lors de la vente d'entreprises
de 34 et demi pour cent elle passe dans
les cas extrêmes à 60%
jeudi après-midi le gouvernement reste
ferme sur ce qu'il appelle une mesure de
justice mais tient à adoucir les angles
pour dresser le pays il faut de la
croissance
il n'y a pas de croissance entrepreneur
il n'ya pas d'entrepreneurs service et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
évolué sur cette question de la taxation
des plus-values de cessions après
négociations les entrepreneurs
bénéficient donc de nombreux allègements
de charges par exemple l'argent de la
vente d'une entreprise est réinvesti
dans la création d'une autre entreprise
n'est pas taxée des mesures qui ont
satisfait les syndicats
tu décides cette réunion mais j'aurais
préféré que ces lieux en amont avant la
publicité la semaine et vendredi soir de
ce pdf plutôt que aujourd'hui il faudra
pas raccrocher les wagons
voilà le gouvernement et les pme
réconcilier pour un temps après un
battage médiatique que la ministre fort
pèlerins a dénoncé comme excessif alors
le mouvement des pigeons dont ces
entrepreneurs c'est chef de startups ont
réussi en moins d'une semaine à faire
reculer le gouvernement
est ce que comme le dit libération à la
une cette semaine il s'est fait
pigeonner mais j'aimais chez c'est vrai
ouais parce que je trouvais amusant le
mot de mots de pigeons c'est joli c'est
un bel oiseau
non ils sont un volet un peu vite voilà
ils sont envolés à plus de peut-être
qu'il avait de bonnes raisons mais sont
envolés un peu vite parce que
heureusement le gouvernement avait pris
en compte déjà dans la loi de finances
mais tous n'étaient pas précis c'est
extrêmement compliqué ce dispositif
de quoi partir par le gouvernement d'une
mesure de justice indispensables
les revenus du capital doivent être
imposés comme les revenus du travail
c'est simple après c'est un tout petit
peu plus compliqué quand on regarde dans
les détails mais faut pas perdre de vue
cela c'est ça une des grandes mesures de
justice de ce projet de
ce projet de loi de finances les revenus
du capital sont imposés comme les
revenus et c'était docker non c'est pas
reculer parce que quand suite quand vous
regardez ce qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
revenus du capital
il ya une très grande différence entre
ça va donner de noms mais telle personne
qui aurait hérité d'une grande quantité
d'actions et qui touchent le revenu de
ces actions a pris beaucoup de risques
il peut être très intelligent avoir
beaucoup de talent n'a pas pris beaucoup
de risques là c'est normal de taxer
exactement comme le travail et puis vous
avez ceux qui sont pas du tout payé
pendant que leurs activités sont partis
de rien qui ont pris beaucoup de risques
ont mis un peu d'argent
et puis à la fin ça vaut cher leur
entreprise ou et c'est normal de ne pas
taxer la vente de cette entreprise
de la même manière qu'eux à ce que
rapportent des actions dont on a dont on
a hérité
vous voyez bien qu'il faut aussi faire
la différence et vous avez vite la
différence principale
c'est en particulier pour ceux qui
réinvestissent le produit de cette vente
quand vous vendez une entreprise qui a
bien marché là on parle de start up en
disant ah vous fait fortune entre
guillemets bien vous gagnez beaucoup
d'argent en vendant votre boîte pas en
étant payés dans la boîte et puis
ensuite vous dites ça seuil est un cas
comme ça qui est bien connu je leur ai
investi dans d'autres boîtes bien il n'y
a pas de raison d'imposer de la même
manière lorsque c'est réinvestis c'est
pas un roc et la confiance à ses patrons
ou pas oui là je pense que c'est ce que
j'y renonce moi je pense que c'était sur
un point très particulier qui est très
médiatisé qui réussit rapidement sur les
ondes sur les tweets sur les réseaux
sociaux je trouve d'ailleurs amusant le
terme de social dans ce cas là mais bon
donc c'est il s'agit là aussi d'être
pertinent et d'être juste voyez bien
comme quoi les mesures globales faut
toujours y faire attention parce que
c'est dans le détail que se trouve que
se niche la difficulté voilà on va
passer aux corniches et c'était à propos
des pigeons tous les élus avaient
rendez-vous sénat peut-être passé
également pour les états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale ce sont des
débats qui ont été lancés il ya un an
par le président du sénat jean-pierre
bel
le but est bien faire évoluer la loi sur
la décentralisation compte rendu de tous
ces débats avec paul bouffard
c'est une véritable armée d'élus locaux
qui envahit le sénat aujourd'hui ils
viennent débattre autour de quatre
thèmes pour repenser la démocratie
territoriale dans les couloirs de la
haute assemblée certains se perdent et
cherchent leurs ateliers
mais tous sont impatients de pouvoir
rénover les relations état collectivités
moi je vais aller à l'atelier a pour
nous intéresser à aux finances c'est
apporter nos expériences et écouter
aussi les propositions que nous ferons
le gouvernement et les ennemis dans les
différents ateliers la parole est libre
les débats s'animent comme ici en salle
des conférences
il est question des conditions
d'exercice du mandat local du statut de
l'élu
moi je pouvais dire qu'il faut ramener
le débat vraiment de manière très
concrète la difficulté que vive le maire
aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est qui c'est
des maires ruraux
au total ils sont 850 élus locaux venus
exprimer leurs inquiétudes
sous l'oeil observateurs du président du
sénat et dans l'hémicycle tous n'ont
qu'un mot à la bouche confiance s'il est
rétabli
puis
maintenant plusieurs années il ya eu de
perte de confiance
le désarroi dont on parle des
collectivités il est l'aîné de ce manque
de confiance
donc on passe du temps vérifiez
réfléchir à la manière dont on peut
recréer cette confiance à la sortie les
élus locaux se sont fait entendre
mais les décisions restent à prendre au
sens moins seul parce qu'on on voit bien
qu'on a les mêmes problématiques
quelles que soient les communes
finalement je pense que les choses à
tirer de ces débats mais ce seront les
choses la marge fins je pense qu'il ya
trop des divergences entre entre les
élus une après-midi de démocratie au
sénat avant la synthèse nationale à la
sorbonne et en attendant la réforme de
la décentralisation prévue début 2013
michel sapin vous avez peut-être entendu
dans ce reportage il ya une certaine
grogne quand même des élus locaux
elle est compréhensible oui parce que
ils ont été traités au cours des deux
dernières années un peu comme des
valeurs d'ajustement on a même cru
abandonné que le déficit de la france
c'était à cause des élus locaux
oui bien que ça n'a rien à voir leur
demander de faire quelques efforts
supplémentaires
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas faire
d'effort c'est pas ça et parce qu'il ya
le déficit de l'état donc c'est le
déficit de l'état qu'il faut combler
donc les collectivités locales sont
globalement bien géré même s'il ya
toujours des choses à améliorer et ne
sont pas responsables de la situation
financière de la france c'est l'état la
sécurité sociale gérée comme c'était
géré qui en sont responsables
et on les a souvent pris à nicolas
sarkozy d'ailleurs je dois arrêter par
migros a régné tout le temps mais
l'esprit y est toujours dira les élus
locaux ils sont trop nombreux
non c'est pas là que se trouve le
problème donc il ya une confiance
effectivement qu'il faut rétablir entre
les élus locaux et l'état
d'autant plus que la décentralisation
nous nous y croyons pour nous c'est
quelque chose de très important
j'ai été longtemps président de région
j'étais maire je le suis pas là depuis
quelques quelques mois ne laissait plus
bas parce que je suis mini c'est normal
mais donc je sais bien ce que c'est je
sais bien ce que c'est que ce travail il
est absolument indispensable
la loi sur la décentralisation arrivera
au printemps prochain
notamment au sénat pour commencer c'est
ce qu'a annoncé le président françois
hollande
a la sorbonne il a également annoncé un
changement du statut de l'élu
et puis et puis bien les prochaines
élections des cantonales et des
régionales bien trop reporter à plus
tard 2015 ces sages oui c'est sage pour
une raison très simple jeu j'entends
tout de suite y en a qui vont te parler
de manipulation et c'est bon pourquoi
parce que nous sommes contre cette
innovation entre guillemets étrange
là c'était pas un pigeon mais pour moi
c'était une chauve souris on avait créé
un nouvel élu qui était à la fois élu au
conseil régional et élu au conseil
général s'appelait le le conseiller
territorial donc on supprime ce
conseiller territorial personne ne
savait de quoi il sait il s'agissait
quand je dis des choses horribles
s'était regardé mais elle je suis oiseau
regarder mon corps aussi sourit donc il
était rien du tout bien donc on supprime
ça et ça veut dire que au lieu d'une
seule élection il ya deux élections on
va pas faire la même année trois
élections
on n'a jamais vu trois urnes les unes à
côté des autres donc il est tout à fait
légitime
ça a été fait déjà plusieurs fois dans
l'histoire de reporter d'un an
l'élection régionale élections
cantonales françois hollande a également
a dit que la loi sur le non-cumul
arriverait donc au printemps prochain
printemps 2013 va falloir convaincre vos
petits collègues ou camarades du parti
socialiste françois rebsamen qui l'a dit
un ne voulait pas renoncer à ses deux
mandats
oui mais là aussi du côté des sénateurs
en particulier je peux tout à fait le
comprendre et la constitution d'ailleurs
dit que le sénat on présente plus
particulièrement les collectivités
locales
il n'empêche que l'on soit sénateurs que
l'on soit députés on est sénateur ou
député de la république donc de
l'ensemble des français et représente
l'ensemble des français je crois qu'à
une page qui se tourne
vous le regrettez moi j'ai été très
longtemps un grand rue muller donc et on
peut le regretter mais il ya une page
qui se tourne et il faut accepter que
les pages se tournent donc nous sommes
rentrés dans une nouvelle ère de la
responsabilité politique au niveau
national comme au niveau local qui fait
qu' il n'y aura plus de cumul entre des
fonctions importantes que l'on reste élu
local
ça me paraît indispensable c'est aussi
la réalité des territoires
mais on peut plus cumuler des fonctions
importantes jean-michel sa part ne
pouvait pas finir cette émission sans
parler d'elle c'est certainement la
femme de la semaine pour la première
fois depuis l'élection de françois
hollande valérie trierweiler est sorti
de son silence pour une interview
mea culpa accordé à ouest-france elle
dit regretter son tweet et renonce à son
projet d'émission pour des
8 en revanche elle conserve sa chronique
dans paris match on dit et de son
indépendance financière alors est ce que
cette interview signifie que vale
trailer assume désormais son rôle de
première dame
mais c'est pas simple parce que plus
tous et pas simplement parce que je
connais personnellement
voilà donc mais j'imagine très bien vous
avez vous pouvez l'imaginer
vous avez une femme qui s'est fait un
nom qui s'est fait une place qui s'est
fait une renommée qui s'est fait qui
parce qu'elle est la vrai talent comme
journaliste un beau métier de
journaliste est ce pas si simple de kars
et c'est pas si simple de bon voilà elle
c'est une vraie personnalité elle était
connue à droite et à gauche
l'interviewait les uns les autres
les présidents de la république les
ministres bon c'était une vraie
personnalité c'est toujours une vraie
personnalité
et tout d'un coup vous dis parce que
vous êtes la femme de ou la compagne de
vous devez renoncer à ça c'est pas
simple je crois que la sagesse veut
effectivement qu'on prenne du recul
qu'on ne s'expose pas que l'on ne puisse
pas mener à bien un certain nombre de
projets professionnels
mais avouez quand même que c'est
difficile à vivre et c'est ce qui s'est
passé ça a été extrêmement difficile à
vivre pour elle
michel sapin est ce que vous estimez que
la vie privée de françois hollande a été
trop exposé pas par lui parce que s'il
ya bien quelqu'un qui n'exposent pas sa
vie privée qui est extrêmement pudique
par rapport à sa vie privée
c'est lui mais quand on est président de
la république par définition tous les
aspects de votre vie sont exposés et les
mâles c'est à lui de le dire mais c'est
quelqu'un qui lorsqu'il a dû bonheur ou
du malheur le montre peu merci beaucoup
merci michel sa merci vim on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine merci bon week-end
à tous à revoir